lisa is with us in spokane washington to
start off
this hour hey lisa what's up hi dave
thanks for taking my call um so here's
the deal
my husband and i were in the process of
building
a house we actually had the foundation
go in last fall
with construction due to resume this
spring
and then we found out last week that our
construction budget went up 40
so we've been on this financial plan to
do this
really intelligently and now it's just
gone off the rails so we're going to put
that on hold
um due to covid and i have this
big chunk of money sitting in our
savings account waiting to pay for this
home
that now we're going it's not working
for us right it's making
what one percent in our savings account
so we'd love to get your advice to have
some thoughts on
whether to just park it in a savings
account we have a rental property
that we owe some money on
we had sold our primary home and i'm
renting a home right now
just could use some direction why'd you
stop building last fall
so it's we're building on in a mountain
environment up at a ski resort
and oh you have to weather exactly
so we put in what you didn't have you
didn't have your materials and all
locked down by contract
so we didn't i feel a little bit let
down by our contractor honestly but we
did not
no so we just found out literally
last week he told us he did he gave us a
revised that's the difference in your
sweet people and me
i wouldn't be a little bit let down i'd
be pissed off like
40 pissed off that was his job to lock
this
up i mean my gosh yeah i'm working with
a contractor right now building a
building or
anticipating a building we're breaking
ground on in two weeks and i've been
wearing them out about locking in
everything because
you can cause the same stuff you're
facing these these shortages on
materials have gone through the roof
caused prices to go through we're gonna
see inflation come back i'm afraid
because of it
uh so how long do you do what is your
guess
on when you actually do build
wait do you think that it will go back
down i mean you don't know
right i don't know well yeah i don't
know economists and weather forecasters
the only
people that can be wrong and keep their
jobs
oh and wait a minute medical doctors
predicting virus infection rates but um
there he did he went they can be wrong
and luke keep their jobs too
but um uh but anyway the uh uh
[Applause]
for me i don't know i i
i do not i am pretty sure you're going
to see something come back down
there's a reason that steel and wood and
lumber and now plywood right behind it
are going through the roof as i
understand it
from the people we're working with in
the business because i've got several
construction projects underway myself
and plywood is actually glue there's a
glue shortage
and that makes the plywood with and so
we're gonna see plywood probably triple
in the next 90 days
is what i'm hearing um and it's already
high lumber packages are
it's the factories were shut down and
they were not producing
uh inventory supply at the rate
even at the rate that it was going
there's not like there was this huge
building spike and the factories were
operating at normal
they weren't operating at all and then
on top of that there was a
good sized spike in building so as the
spike slows down and the factories get
back to capacity
supply demand curve is going to drop
these prices down steel is not going to
stay where it is
not for not for five years it might for
24 months though
i don't know i i don't know on that but
um
so it so the answer to your question is
how long do you think you're parking the
money
the longer you're going to park the
money the more you're going to want to
put some of it into something like an
index fund
and take a little bit of risk with it to
get a little bit more money
so it could be two to three years okay
so you're thinking i would love it
you emotionally are prepared for a
two-year storm okay i
don't know that you're wrong on that um
so
i'm curious dave how much do you owe on
the rental property
okay so we owe 103 on the property and i
have 180
000 sitting in the savings account okay
when you get ready to build would you be
willing to sell the rental if you had
paid it off and needed the money
if i need to we definitely would do that
yeah
because yeah i mean i mean why i was
wondering
that's a really safe place to get a
three or four percent rate of return on
that hundred grand
pay that mortgage off okay ken's got a
point that's where he's going i jumped
the gun but yeah that's that's what you
were thinking
how much money is in savings for this
building project
so i have a 180 in savings and we
already have you know we own the land
outright and we have no debt on
the foundation in and done so we already
have you know
a hundred thousand people parked over
there in concrete right now but that's
that's not here there you're not going
to tear that down so yeah
yeah i i you know you could either do
one of three things or some mix of them
pay off the home
the rental and then be willing to sell
it when you get her back up because
you're gonna need the cash back out of
it i'm not gonna turn around and borrow
back on it
uh if you do that that's kind of a point
of no return on that
the second thing is you could park some
in an index fund index funds are gonna
follow the market whatever it does
uh i mean you could lose ten percent of
what you put in there over a two year
period of time it'd be
highly unusual the number of times a two
year period in the stock market's
history is down ten percent
like two percent of the time or
something it almost never happens
but it could i park stuff for short term
like that
if i can afford to lose the spread lose
five or ten percent on it
uh in an index fund and you might make
ten percent
instead of one percent on that portion
and then some of it you park in just
cash
and that's your safety bellwether
so i probably wouldn't do the rental and
the index fund i'd do one or the other
and leave the other half in just cash
yeah okay she got half of it real safe
half of it's either in that rental and
into the or into the index fund
that kind of thing hey thanks for the
call yeah can there the next generation
of elementary school teachers
google kids are going to be uh fuji math
it's a whole new form of mathematics is
that right yeah it's where you just make
crap
up yeah i like that well can i just say
this as a parent of three that went
through common core i think somebody
made that up too
[Laughter]
well that's just because you can't
understand it i don't know take a survey
right now i'm telling you
nobody knows what common core is it's
unbelievable it's like they cut it you
got to go out
it's like having a perfectly nate
brigadier it's like saying
the front door works but we're not going
to go through the front door because the
way we do it now is we walk all the way
around jump over the fence and come in
the back door
yeah that's common core it's more fun
for you
i don't even know how that part of your
brain works i don't even know how to do
it i've never tried
this whole side of my head with math
dave it's exploded no there's nothing
there oh there's just nothing there it's
empty doctors have found no wavelength
there's nothing in there
no activity no brain activity it's
almost like you're a medical doctor
yes you can't do math yeah oh my gosh